économie environnement énergie eau
sociale le développement durable à la
Réunion c'est
[Musique]
maintenant bonjour aujourd'hui nous
allons vous présenter un écoogeste pour
éviter de gaspiller de l'énergie en
classe
l'été j'y vais
moi monsieur monsieur monsieur vous
pouvez allumer les ventilateurs s'il
vous plaît oui moi je pense qu'il faut
ouvrir les nacos ah oui oui non mais moi
je préfère je préfère allumer les
ventilateur c'est ça ça produit plus d'
on arrête tout on va procéder à un vote
qui est pour les
ventilateurs trois élèves qui est pour
les
nacos une majorité pour les nacos voyez
quand on s'explique on arrive à se
mettre d'c d'accord donc ça sera les
[Musique]
NA les ventilateur en été c'est pas
automatique comme le montre ce drapeau
qui flotte à l'entrée du collège depuis
juin 2009 le collège gendesme est
labellisé écoécole au collège gendesme
nous incitons chacun à adopter des
écogestes pour qu'il y ait plus de
solidarité entre nous pour améliorer
notre cadre de vie et pour respecter
l'environnement je peux économiser
jusqu'à 140 € sur mes factures F comment
j'éteins les lumières en quittant la
pièce ainsi que l'ordinateur la radio la
chaîne et le téléviseur quand ceuxci ne
sont pas utilisés j'are les pièces en
faisant des courants d'air le matin et
en été je ferme les volets ou je tire
les rideaux alors vous voyez préserver
l'environnement c'est augmenter votre
pouvoir d'achat le Conseil Général agit
pour le développement durable et
[Musique]
vous économie environnement énergie eau
social le développement durable à la
Réunion c'est
[Musique]
maintenant